- Nun chuck skills,
bow hunting skills,
computer hacking skills.
Girls only want boyfriends
who have great skills.
(loud sigh)
- No, no.
It wasn't a question.
- Hi, Omari Hardwick, five foot 10.
Reading for the part of Miranda Priestly.
Is there some reason my coffee isn't here?
Is she sick or something?
Ugh.
- Hi, I'm Jermaine Fowler.
I'll be reading for Miranda Priestly
for Devil Wears Prada.
Floral?
For spring?
(bleep) How ground breaking.
- No, no, no, no.
That wasn't a question.
- Next line?
Sorry.
(clears throat)
That's all.
Do you need (bleep)?
You need that.
Without it, you don't have any real...
I don't...
I love that word for...
Thank you.
There's more.
- You know, like
nun chuck skills,
bow hunting skills,
computer hacking skills.
Girls only want boyfriends
who have good skills.
- Hey, I'm Jermaine Fowler.
I am reading for Napoleon,
Napoleon Dynamite.
Hey.
I see you drinking 1%.
Does that mean you think you're fat?
'Cause you're not.
You could be drinking
whole if you wanted to.
Okay, next side.
- Nun chuck skills,
bow hunting skills,
computer hacking skills.
Girls only want boyfriends
who have great skills.
(deep sigh)
- It's a liger.
It's pretty much my favorite animal.
It's like a tiger and a lion mixed.
It's bred for it's skills in magic.
- Tina, you fat lard.
Come get me some dinner.
- Is butter a carb?
- Omari Hardwick, again, five foot 10.
Reading for the part of Regina George.
It's Mean Girls, one
of my favorite movies.
Just thought I would add that.
Get in, loser.
We're going shopping.
- Why do you wear your hair like that?
Your hair looks so sexy pushed back.
Kadie, can you tell him
his hair looks sexy when it's pushed back?
- Get in, loser.
We're going shopping.
- Jason, you do not come to a party
at my house with Gretchen
and then scam on some poor, innocent girl
right in front of us three days later.
So you can go shave your back now.
- Wait,
is butter a carb?
No?
Great.
- Jason,
you do not come to a party
at my house with Gretchen
and then scam on some poor, innocent girl
right in front of us three days later.
So you can go shave your back, now.
(grunts)
(bleep)
How was that?
It felt real, it felt right.
It felt good?
Did I get that (bleep)?
I got that (bleep).
(dramatic music)